one of the best things that a a film
director today can do for an actor is
not be stuck in video Village I'm not
sitting there at video Village in
another room watching TV all right uh
while my movie's being made not be
watching it on a monitor and not be
watching it on a TV set sitting in a
chair oftentimes in a whole other room
hey do this do a camera lip could you
tell him to go into a camera you work
too hard to be watching TV while the
most exciting moment of your life is
happening you should be sitting right by
the camera I'm uh wherever the camera is
I'm shooting this young lady who's
sitting right here with glasses I'm
right here looking right at her and here
we go if you watch the acting
right next to the camera
right in front of the actors
it's as if they are acting just and
solely and utterly only for you